and young athletes and I raced here
in the past I drove my father's chariot
[Music]
yeah
quebec the avignon festival we share a
lot of common concerns,
such as giving as many
people as possible access to culture
regardless of their age or social origin and
that's really been a goal to go
into since its creation
it's a little
m
tomoneyweek
[Music]
the lions festival is an
extremely important meeting place for exchanges
the profession the
profession broadly and in the
international sense seemed quite
natural to welcome future professional
at 5 p.m.
m
[Music]
I'm not a cop
all
yes but
how
[Music]
it's true more
Tyler
[Music]